but we begin with chief White House
correspondent John Roberts on the North
Lawn good even John Brackett evening to
you the president has said repeatedly
that it's better to work with Russia
than it is to work against them today he
was forced to work against them in a
rare rebuke to Russia President Trump
today joined with UK prime minister
Theresa May condemning last week's nerve
agent attack in Britain pointing the
finger squarely at Vladimir Putin the
very sad situation it certainly looks
like the Russians were behind it
something that should never ever happen
and were taking it very seriously the
White House acknowledges it was relying
on British analysis of the attack
against former Russian spies Sergei
skree pal and his daughter but left open
the question of whether President Trump
will follow the UK in penalizing the
Kremlin specifics on any potential
threats but I can't tell you that we're
gonna continue to work with our ally in
the United Kingdom and will work in
close coordination with them moving
forward we'll keep you posted if any
specific actions the Treasury Department
did impose penalties today on 13
Russians indicted by robert muller for
meddling in the u.s. election Treasury
blocked access to property in the US
financial system for them five companies
that supported their activity and
another six people the US says were
acting on behalf of the Russian
government on Capitol Hill applause for
the move from president Trump's
Republican colleagues somebody said that
mr. Putin wakes up every day wondering
where the United States is having
problems and wonders how can I make it
worse this sort of thing needs to be
responded to needs to be punished the
senate minority leader who has fiercely
criticized the president for not
imposing sanctions found a way to
criticize him today for imposing them in
a statement chuck schumer saying the
sanctions proved molars investigation is
not a witch-hunt as the president and
his allies have claimed it's more clear
than ever that the president must not
interfere with the special counsels
investigation in any way at the same
time treasury was announcing sanctions
DHS and the FBI warned that russian
hackers are trying to infiltrate the
american energy grid at his confirmation
hearing to lead the National Security
Agency
general Paul Nakasone painting it as a
matter of grave concern certainly the
entire defense of our you know
electrical system within our critical
infrastructure is of great concern to me
I am aware that there has been reporting
with regards to elements within within
our ICS and SCADA systems that's
something that should concern all of us
in the Oval Office with Ireland's Prime
Minister for the annual st. Patrick's
Day visit today president Trump weighed
in on personnel changes
shooting down chatter that more cabinet
and staff departures are imminent so
they'll always be changed but very
little it was a very false story it was
very very exaggerated a very exaggerated
and false story but they'll always be
change and I think you want to see
change and I want to also see different
ideas one potential personnel change the
White House is watching closely the
Attorney General's decision whether to
fire FBI deputy director Andrew McCabe
before he retires on Sunday that's a
determination that we would leave up to
attorney general sessions but we do
think that it is well documented that he
has had some very troubling behavior and
by most accounts a bad actor and should
have some cause for concern and one
other piece of news the Trump
Organization today was pushing back
against a report that the Muller
investigation is taking a new twist by
issuing the Trump Organization a
subpoena asking for documents related to
Russia and other issues some people
familiar with the investigation say the
Trump Organization has been providing
documents to Muller for months an
attorney in a statement to Fox News
saying quote since July 2017 we have
advised the public that the Trump
Organization is fully cooperative with
all investigations including the Special
Counsel and is responding to their
requests this is old news and our
assistance in cooperation with the
various investigations remains the same
today
Bret John Roberts Levin North Lawn John
thanks